Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
"Hola, Bob".
"Buen día, Kelly.
Los tulipanes se ven muy bien".
¿Te has preguntado cómo experimenta
el mundo tu perro?
Esto es lo que ve.
Nada muy interesante.
Pero lo que huele, eso sí es
una historia totalmente diferente.
Todo empieza con un olfato
muy desarrollado.
Conforme atrapa los primeros
indicios de aire fresco,
la humedad del morro esponjoso externo
ayuda a captar los aromas de la brisa.
La capacidad de oler por separado
por cada fosa nasal,
de oler en estéreo,
ayuda a determinar la dirección
de la fuente de olor.
Así que en los primeros
momentos de la inhalación,
empieza a darse cuenta no solo
de las cosas que hay allí
sino de dónde están ubicadas.
Conforme entra el aire
un pequeño pliegue de tejido
lo divide en dos sectores
uno para respirar
y otro solo para oler.
Este segundo flujo de aire
entra en una zona
llena de células receptoras olfativas
altamente especializadas,
varios cientos de millones de ellas,
comparadas con nuestros 5 millones.
Y, a diferencia de nuestra torpe respiración
bidireccional por el mismo pasaje,
los perros exhalan por unas ranuras
que tienen a un lado del morro
que crean remolinos de aire que ayudan
a atraer nuevas moléculas de olor
y eso les permite acumular olor
en olfateos múltiples.
Pero una arquitectura nasal tan
impresionante, no sería de mucha ayuda
sin algo que procesara
esas cargas de información nasal.
Y es que el sistema olfativo
dedicado al procesamiento de olores
ocupa relativamente mucho más espacio en
el cerebro canino que en el humano.
Todo esto le permite
a los perros distinguir
y recordar variedades asombrosas
de aromas específicos
en concentraciones hasta de
100 millones de veces menores
que lo que podemos detectar.
Si tú puedes oler un chorrito de perfume
en una habitación pequeña,
un perro no tendría problemas para olerlo
en un estadio cerrado
y distinguir sus ingredientes,
para arrancar.
Y todo en la calle,
cada persona o auto que pasa,
cualquier contenido de
la basura del vecino,
cada tipo de árbol,
las aves e insectos que contiene
tienen un perfil distinto de olor que
le revela a tu perro qué es, dónde está,
y en qué dirección se mueve.
Además de ser mucho
más poderoso que el nuestro,
el sentido del olfato de un perro
puede detectar cosas que no se ven.
Todo un sistema olfativo separado,
llamado órgano vomeronasal,
encima del paladar,
detecta las hormonas que todos
los animales liberan naturalmente,
incluyendo el ser humano.
Eso permite a los perros
identificar posibles parejas,
o distinguir entre animales
amigos y hostiles.
Les avisa de nuestros distintos
estados emocionales,
e incluso puede saber
si alguien está embarazada o enfermo.
Como el olfato es más primario
que otros sentidos,
no pasa por el tálamo y directamente
conecta con las estructuras del cerebro
encargadas de la emoción y los instintos.
Podríamos decir que la percepción del perro
es más inmediata y visceral que la nuestra.
Pero lo más sorprendente
del olfato canino
es que puede atravesar el tiempo.
Aparece el pasado en las pistas
dadas por los transeúntes,
y en el calor de un auto
estacionado recientemente,
en el residuo existente en el lugar
y en lo que has hecho recientemente.
Lugares emblemáticos como
hidrantes y árboles
que tienen mensajes de quiénes pasaron,
qué comieron,
y cómo se sentían.
Y el futuro está en la brisa,
que alerta de algo o alguien que se acerca,
mucho antes de verlo.
Para cuando vemos y escuchamos algo
en un momento dado,
un perro huele una historia completa
de principio a fin.
En algunos de los mejores ejemplos
de colaboración-canino humano,
los perros nos ayudan compartiendo
y reaccionando a esas historias.
Pueden responder con amabilidad
a las personas en peligro,
o con agresión a las amenazas
porque el estrés y la ira se manifiestan
como una nube de hormonas
reconocible al olfato del perro.
Con el entrenamiento adecuado,
incluso nos pueden alertar
de amenazas invisibles
desde bombas hasta cáncer.
Pues resulta que,
el mejor amigo del hombre
no es el que experimenta
las mismas cosas que nosotros,
sino aquel cuyo olfato increíble revela
otro mundo más allá de nuestra vista.